when I was a kid my understanding of the
seasons was that December and January
were cold and covered with snow April
and May were bursting with flowers July
and August were hot and sunshiny and
September and October were a
kaleidoscope of colorful leaves it was
just the way the world worked and it was
magical if you had told me back then
that one-third of Earth's population had
never seen snow or that July 4th was
most definitely not a beach day I would
have thought you were crazy but in
reality seasonal change with four
distinct seasons only happens in two
regions on the planet and even in those
two the seasons are reversed but why a
lot of people have heard of an
astronomer called Johannes Kepler and
how he proved that the planetary orbits
are elliptical and that the Sun is not
at the center of the orbit it was a big
deal when he figured this out several
hundred years ago his discovery solved a
lot of mathematical problems that the
strana Murs were having with planetary
orbit measurements while it's true that
our orbits not perfectly circular those
pictures in our science books on TV and
in the movies give an exaggerated
impression of how elongated our orbit is
in fact Earth's orbit is very nearly a
perfect circle however because Earth's
orbit is technically an ellipse even
though it doesn't look like one and the
Sun isn't quite exactly at the center it
means that our distance from the Sun
does change through the year aha so
winter happens when the earth is further
away from the Sun well no not so fast
the earth is actually closer to the Sun
in January than we are in July by five
million kilometers January is smack dab
in the middle of the coldest season of
the year for those of us up north
still not convinced how about this
summer in winter occurs simultaneously
on the surface of our planet when it's
winter in Connecticut it's summer in New
Zealand so if it's not the distance from
the Sun what else could it be
well we need to also know that the earth
doesn't sit straight up it actually
tilts and that axial tilt of the earth
is one of the main reasons for the
seasons the Earth spins on an axis
that's tilted 23.5 degrees from vertical
at the same time the Earth revolves
around the Sun with the axis always
pointing in the same
and space together with the tilt the
spinning and revolving causes the number
of hours of day lay in a region to
change as the year goes by with more
hours in summer and fewer in winter so
when the sun is shining on the earth it
warms up after the Sun sets it has time
to cool down so in the summer any
location that's about 40 degrees north
of the Equator like Hartford Connecticut
will get 15 hours of daylight each day
and nine hours of darkness it warms up
for longer than it cools this happens
day after day so there's an overall
warming effect remember this fact for
later in the winter the opposite happens
there are many more hours of cooling
time than warming time and day after day
this results in a cooling effect the
interesting thing is as you move north
the number of daylight hours in summer
increases so Juneau Alaska would get
about 19 hours of daylight on the same
summer day that Tallahassee Florida gets
about 14 in fact in the summer time at
the North Pole the Sun never sets okay
then it's all about daylight hours I've
got it
well no there's another important piece
to this puzzle
if daylight hours were the only thing
that determined average temperature
wouldn't the North Pole be the hottest
place on earth and northern summer
because it receives 24 hours of daylight
in the months surrounding the summer
solstice
but it's the North Pole there's still
icebergs in the water and snow on the
ground so what's going on the earth is a
sphere and so the amount of solar energy
an area receives changes based on how
high the Sun is in the sky which as you
know changes during the day between
sunrise and sunset but the maximum
height also changes during the year with
the greatest solar height during the
summer months and highest of all at noon
on the summer solstice which is June
21st in the Northern Hemisphere and
December 21st and the southern
hemisphere this is because as the Earth
revolves the Northern Hemisphere ends up
tilted away from the Sun in the winter
and toward the Sun and summer which puts
the Sun more directly overhead for
longer amounts of time remember those
increased summertime daylight hours and
solar energy per square kilometer
increases as the Sun gets higher in the
sky so when the Sun is at an angle the
amount of energy delivered to each
square of the sunlit area is less
therefore
or even though the North Pole is getting
24 hours of daylight to warm up the
sunlight it receives is very spread out
and delivers less energy than a place
for their South where the Sun is higher
in the sky because it's more tilted
toward the Sun
besides the North Pole has a lot to make
up for it was cooling down without any
sunlight at all for six months straight
so as the seasons change wherever you
are you can now appreciate not just the
beauty of each new season but the
astronomical complexity that brings them
to you